It's hot.
You're hungry.
You've got nothing better to do.
Why not fry an egg on the sidewalk?
You will need: eggs, aluminum foil, a mirror or magnifying glass, and a very, very hot sidewalk.
Optional: Butter or oil, and salt and pepper.
Step 1: The temperature of the sidewalk needs to reach at least 158 degrees Fahrenheit to turn a raw egg solid.
Sorry, a light - colored sidewalk on its own won't do the trick.
You'll need to cheat just a little.
Step 2: The easiest and most sanitary way to fry an egg on the sidewalk is to use a piece of aluminum foil.
Take a pan - size piece of foil and bend the edges up,...
...so the raw egg doesn't slide onto the pavement.
Step 3: Crack an egg or two onto the foil.
The sun will reflect off the surface and cook your eggs.
If you intend to eat these eggs,...
...you might wanna use some butter or oil on the tin foil so it doesn't stick.
And season your eggs with some salt and pepper.
Step 4: To speed up the process,...
...use a magnifying glass or mirror to focus the sun rays on the foil.
Now you're cooking!
Step 5: After your egg is cooked,...
...tell everyone that it was so hot outside that you were able to fry an egg on the sidewalk.
They'll either think you are most egg-zelent or just egg-zagerating.
Did you know? Every 4th of July, Oatman, Arizona has a solar egg - frying contest.